نتابع لان هذه الصور التي وردتنا قبل قليل
وهي مشاهد
لانتشار الجيش السوداني في بعض
المناطق والشوارع في العاصمه السودانيه في
اي مناطق هذه لنا
هل يمكن تحديد منطقه
متاكده حتى اللحظه لا يظهر معلم واضح في
هذا الشارع
الان هذه المدرعات هذه الاليات التابعه
للجيش السوداني وهي تتحرك ربما في احدى
المناطق من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
في اشاره واضحه ربما الى اتساع رقعه
المواجهات والاشتباكات التي تشهدها مناطق
متفرقه من العاصمه السوداني
ايضا رقع التمدد الجيش لانني ذكرت قبل
قليل ان الدعم السريع منتشر في عدد من
الشوارع في العاصمه
فحركه الجيش هذا يدل ويشير الى ان الجيش
الان يعني يتحرك في عدد من المناطق وعدد
من الشوارع لابعاد الدعم السريع عن مناطق
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات